it's easy to imagine the life of an
actor from a hit TV show is jumping from
one role to the next but even talented
performers sometimes have periods where
it's hard to find work sadly that has
been the case for actress Deborah Ann
Woll
who co-starred in several of Netflix's
now-defunct Marvel properties most
notably daredevil since the series was
cancelled in 2018 while say she has so
far been unable to land a follow-up role
in an emotional interview on the youtube
series show qs morning warm-up hosted by
legendary comics artist and current
marvel creative director joe quesada
wall opened up about her struggles with
navigating the industry and how the lull
in her career has affected her as she
put it if I'm not acting I'm not sure
who I am you know it's been two years
since daredevil finished wilmore two and
a half years and I haven't had matching
job since and that's been really hard
for me she also opened up about the tall
working as an artist at a tumultuous
industry can take on a person's sense of
self-worth
I'm just really wondering whether
whether I'll get to work again and
whether anyone wants to work with me
again and whether I still have it all of
those scary things
what makes Wolves plight all the more
shocking is the fact that she's well
really good at her job if you never
caught her work on daredevil you've
still probably seen her on some other
hit TV series over the last decade or so
it was only after a handful of guest
spots on Laura Nora and ER that while
finally managed to land her breakout
role one that many people probably still
recognize her from in 2008 she was cast
in the HBO series True Blood as Jessica
Hamby a timid young woman raised in a
deeply religious household who underwent
a bit of a personality change when she
was turned into a vampire and introduced
to all the powers that came with a
supernatural status in a show full of
memorable characters Jessica was one of
the best lights
thanks in no small part to walls
performance which found just the right
balance of innocence and edge how do you
know I'm an ass girl because of your
smile she even had her own web spin-off
series of shorts called Jessica's blog
which was meant to expand the True Blood
universe successfully doing so with 38
episodes over the course of several
years
hey everyone I've had a little too much
time on my hands lately when True Blood
ended in 2014 it was nice
surprised that while quickly lined up a
next high-profile TV gig starring as the
assertive journalist Karen page on
daredevil while also appeared as Karen
in the crossover series the defenders
she also appeared in another Marvel
Netflix series The Punisher in which her
character was originally not intended to
appear but showrunner Steve Lightfoot
changed his mind about that after seeing
the chemistry between wall and Punisher
actor Jon Bernthal who made his debut as
antihero frank castle in daredevil
second season Lightford said during a
presser I asked to have her because she
and Frank are so great
Frank is a closed-off Mellet airy guy
and this is a woman he treats like an
equal more than anyone else
Quezada who served as an executive
producer on daredevil both empathize
with wildin expressed surprise that she
would have trouble finding work first of
all my man yeah Joe hit the ground
because you're an amazing town it wasn't
the only former coworker of walls to
speak up about her talents as an actor
after the interview walls daredevil
co-star and screen legend Vincent
D'Onofrio tweeted his support Deborah
Ann Woll can play any part written for
an actor to play I think of her as being
one of my favorite scene partners in my
career because of her talent every actor
depends on their scene partner you'd be
lucky to have her with you unstoppable a
gift to storytelling Byrne Thor applied
to that tweet to offer his own support
writing that right there's the truth big
love to both of y'all it's an honor and
joy to have rolled with you guys with so
much support from those who have worked
closely with her let's hope the enter
walls dry spell comes quickly in the
meantime you can still check out her
work on the Netflix Marvel series or
stream the entirety of True Blood on
Hulu check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
you